wir haben schon wieder angemerkt hat er
einfach nur kanal reifen bieten den
menschen näher zu beschreiben was
passiert und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute die leute gibt
es die zweite folge von heftig bh von
bitterer auf den formaten dem ich eine
volle youtube kommentare durchlese alle
die die erste folge schon gewinnen
wittert einen historischen markt in der
farbe schlag das sind gesperrt
die kommentare kommentare die mine
automatisch verbirgt wird hat die
eigentlich niemand sie die sind für
immer in den weiten von youtube
verschwunden aber wir kommen wieder auf
diesem format und wir leben direkt mit
dem flop brachte doch schön da freut
mich dass du hast du sehen macht einfach
beim menschen einfach nett sind einfach
ohne grund aber mit freundlichkeit
zeigen zum beispiel so wie geil
wer schreibt [ __ ] eine sache die
ich einfach nicht verstehe warum
kommentiert einfach jemanden dem
eifelort derzeit nur ein wort das wort
hat nicht mal irgendeinen sinn und war
patrick dokumentiert mit kanal was
möchte ich unter mit dahin üblichen
löhne geheime botschaft der illuminaten
oder oder wollte er testen ob ich
tatsächlich das wollen kanal blockiert
habe häufige stammt selbstverständlich
von der psychologe und er schreibt zur
lenkung wirkt ein bisschen geld machst
du nicht sagen wo wir schon beim thema
tipps sind das ist natürlich immer
wichtig dass künftig ausführlich
formuliert wird die arctic morgen
gewissen flug zu dem video haben wir
neben stehst du der person die das video
gemacht hätten den befehl und generell
ein fachgebiet hand besteht deswegen
freue ich mich ganz besonders über
wertvolle feedback von tuna ünal wenn
wer dachte sich seine ersten folge die
ersten video von kuchen wurde okay das
hat mir auch noch nie in der folge dass
sich die kommentare selbst verantwortet
haben denn wir haben jetzt hier einen
von mpdv der schlag einfach natürlich
das bleibt jetzt mal so stehen langsam
erkenne ich da irgend eine systematik
gibt irgendeine versteckte logik
dahinter wir haben schon wieder einen
moment hat er einfach nur kanal reif
bewegliche menschen zu beschreiben was
auf jeden fall die d mark bekommen haben
und er schreibt das kann ich eigentlich
alles vor lieber wegsehen der
kommentarfeld an mit able schlange
ringer hör auf mit fuß willst doch nun
mit einer deutschen de wird bietet wie
auch ein rtl mitarbeiter der sport
geboten möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen bisschen was leute ich bin ich
jetzt mal alle von den kommentaren
waffen spielten konnten auch deutlich
merken versicherten konnte sag ich immer
bei sowas deutschen fragt ihr euch das
mich auch wie entsteht so etwas weil
jeder einzelne kommentare man wie jeder
einfach live kommentaren wurde von einer
person geschrieben person er sich
hingesetzt hat sich gedacht weiß was
heute sonntag die sonne scheint nicht
ich habe schlechte laune und ich habe
jetzt genau diesen kommentaren haben wir
auch jeden gast über noch ein spiel die
gedachte erkannt ausrichten heißt
nämlich kevin müller betreibt ein
banales gail posner gesteine kommentare
die geblockt werden wind einfach alles
kommentare mit canal canal hier mal da
wladimir putin youtube-kanal fehlt ein
kanal super ich habe mir beim kanal die
100 warum shriver das unter einem video
in dem ich gesagt habe dass sowas doch
blöd ist ganz ehrlich was im großen
probleme wenn man solche formate machte
formate in dem man auf dumme kommentare
eingeht alle fangen an absichtlich
solche kommentare zu schreiben menschen
ist ziemlich abstoßend sehr schön da
haben wir hier ein kommentar von
schlaghose dieser kommentar kündet von
vor einer sehr speziellen begabungen
da haben wir wirklich einen sehr
intelligenten mitbürger je gefunden
klagte schreibt kuchen tv ist ein
richtiger kommt jetzt nur mehr anzeigen
du hast den job nicht gedacht oder der
job mit kuchen die frauen mehr anzeigen
war egal wer du willst kuchenverkauf hat
mehr anzeigen das war der job nicht gut
ist ein richtiger mehr anzeigt was ist
ein richtiger mehr anzeigen klaglose ich
finde deinen kommentar wirklich
abstoßend und fast wirklich unfassbar
ich gehe diese kommentare durch und in
jedem kommentar steht
mir gefällt ein canal canal nur viele
leute dachten sie einfach herkommen ich
probier's mal auch wirklich kanal
geblockt wird
na klar dass geblockt ich habe für mich
ausgesagt werden wirklich alle
kommentare wie der sportkanal enthalten
geblockt deswegen leute kann man
versprechen
die kommentare werden geblockt und ich
hab ich versprechen dass sie auch nicht
in videos bekommen exakt hey leute
wirklich der hammer die gibt es wirklich
leute die ich bin habe ich vorhin sich
genau das haben wollen - leute die
schreiben einfach du [ __ ] jeskell
nicht böse gemeint ich möchte einfach
nur in einem video reinkommen canal du
[ __ ]
wir haben wieder ein intelligent wolken
und wahrheit der gute care als lukas
wichmann dieser bescheidene
nobelpreisträger kommentiert mit die
tierschutz-organisation mit peter es
wirklich peter lueg ag
warum sollte man eine
tierschutzorganisation peta ein camp für
die tierschutzorganisation horst nein
warum seine tiefs organisation peta
geben wwf man über du kannst auch nicht
gewinn weiter führt also douglas fraser
glauben nach oben läuft flüssigkeit v3
macht ja